vamos en el norte de la capital en
bogotá y aquí lo que estamos viviendo es
un clima de represión la fuerza pública
está reprimiendo a los manifestantes que
han llegado hasta el norte de la ciudad
algo inusual porque las manifestaciones
suelen congregarse en el sur y en el
centro del país pero han llegado hasta
el norte con el motivo de que el
presidente iván duque vivía acá en el
norte en un barrio residencial y hasta
aquí ha llegado la fuerza pública que
está reprimiendo con gases lacrimógenos
también está lanzando aturdidoras e
incluso han metido una tanqueta algo que
nunca se había visto en esta parte de la
ciudad los manifestantes están
dispersados por varias calles de aquí de
la una de las vías principales de bogotá
pero mientras tanto la fuerza de
seguridad con pequeños intervalos pero
continúan lanzando gases lacrimógenos y
aturdidoras contra los decenas de
manifestantes nos dicen que los
manifestantes vienen del sur que son
jóvenes que han subido desde els de la
ciudad hasta el norte